how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder
it's been really hard ever since we
heard of the passing of
chadwick boseman he was a huge
huge role model to the community and i
think if there's anything that we've
learned about him over this past week
is that he was truly a remarkable person
he fought colon cancer for many years
but he never told
anybody outside of his immediate family
for the most part
the president of marvel studios kevin
feige didn't even know until he passed
away
and during this time while he was
fighting cancer he filmed
many different films including black
panther infinity war and avengers
in-game and he did it all for
the fans he did it all for the community
and that says a lot about a person and
everybody is truly saddened that he's
gone
but in some fortunate news it sounds
like we do have
one more mcu project to look forward to
with chadwick boseman in it and that is
marvel's what if
animated series coming in phase four and
if the reports are true and they do come
from
a very credible source it's going to be
a heck of a show and a heck of a good
way to remember
chadwick boseman now we know that all of
the original
mcu actors are going to be returning to
record their own voices for marvel's
animated series what if
and as it seems some of the actors have
already been in the studio recording
their voices
and according to insider daniel richman
chadwick boseman had already done his
episode and finished
his parts daniel richman reported on
twitter saying
i hear chadwick already recorded his
lines for what if
so this will truly be the last time
we'll see slash here
his t'challa a sad statement but also
something to look forward to
hearing him play his character one last
time now of course we know that marvel's
what if animated series is going to be a
little bit different than anything the
mcu has ever done
but fortunately for us we do know what
chadwick boseman's black panther episode
is going to be about
it's going to be about t'challa
adventuring through the galaxy as
a different version of star lord and
this was confirmed
last year as footage was released at
disney's d23 expo in which we can see
the expanding the universe special on
disney plus that shows a single
animated shot from guardians of the
galaxy of star lord and morag
however the person underneath star
lord's helmet is not peter quill
it's t'challa the showrunner for
marvel's what if series is
ashley bradley and in an interview with
discussing film here's what she had to
say about the specific
what if t'challa was star-lord episode
she said
with star-lord t'challa obviously we
want to know how t'challa ended up
on other planets what's the story there
it's super exciting to work on because
again
it's seeing these characters and seeing
the combination of character
interactions
now as far as the answer to this
specific episode
what if t'challa became star-lord it'll
definitely be fun to see play out but
the question
of how he became star-lord is a little
bit unknown right now
perhaps some people from wakanda went to
outer space to explore a little bit or
perhaps yondu
in his abduction of many different kids
to send to ego abducted t'challa
as far as why he ends up as star-lord
and ends up on other planets
we don't know but it's certainly going
to be fun to see play out
and it's most likely going to be funny
as well since star-lord is pretty much
known for being funny and that'll be a
great way to hear chadwick boseman for
the final time in the marvel cinematic
universe cheerful
happy and doing what he loves and not to
mention they'll also probably do
a memorial for him or some sort of a
tribute before his episode so
of course right now it's still very hard
and a lot of people of course are still
mourning
but there is a slight bit of joy as
we'll probably get to hear him
one more time as his character black
panther t'challa in marvel's what if
series
so let me know what you think about this
news in the comments down below
and let me know how you think t'challa
will end up as star lord and marvel's
what if series
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a
hawkeye funko pop i'm picking a winner
on monday i'm also giving away some
funko pops on
instagram and twitter so don't forget to
follow me on there and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof